what movie do you think you've seen the
most
cable guy really yeah
is there like a was there like a summer
that you watched it all the time
oh my god it was when i was growing up
my my brother's best friends had seen
dumb and dumber
nine million times and quoted the whole
film and since we couldn't compete with
them we'd figured we'd
you know we'd go our own path and make
our
you know have our flick we could do that
with and that became cable guy
i've seen it well over 100 times
it wasn't expecting that but that's a
good choice yeah
you know um you've made a lot of
different
movies and i'm imagining what were you
expecting just by curious a little
uh oh no cool hand luke or oh no not
believe me i've heard every possible
answer the best is when you get someone
saying like um
you know close encounters and frozen too
and i'm like wait what and then i
realized they have kids
yeah you know um but i've heard i've
heard everything like
so many things nothing there's no and by
the way there's no right answer it's
just
no no of course not i mean you know a
strong second would probably be cool and
luke or
you know hud or so but yeah cable guy
sorry no it's great
um you've worked on so many different
movies when you look back
on the many projects you've worked on
what ended up being a lot more
challenging than you expected
pan was very challenging we're on a
stage the whole time
um uh isolated
outside of london um
i was staying at a hotel like an hour
outside of london
um and you know we're working on these
stages
the outside of bedford which is where
they had
um where they had built like the
zeppelin
um and so these massive stages that
basically had their own ecosystem
where where uh from the frozen ice over
the winter
in the spring it would rain inside these
things and they were just
just massive but you know five or six
months
in in these things um you know
working on very heavy special effects
um kind of film other than that oddly
enough
was um was mud bound very
very quick shoot and then emotionally
draining
the weather was raining um out there in
in
new orleans um uh and it was it was a
very dramatic piece but
you know the weather definitely added to
that out there i looked up all the
the great directors you've worked with
from the coen brothers angley
chill wright lee daniels i mean the list
goes on and on and on
i'm curious is there a common trait that
all these gifted directors you've worked
with have
or is each time you stand on set working
for someone like this
is it like just a completely different
experience due to the way
they like to run the set yeah it's i i
think it's a
it's it's really been a completely
different experience and that's why i've
enjoyed
you know striving to work with
you know all of them being able to work
with all of them has been such a gift
seeing all the different variations of
techniques the way they run their sets
um
you know what they crave within their
performances
sort of either honesty naturalism
you know just comfortability and and and
relaxation you know um
[Music]
yeah it's it's interesting some
you know working with someone like
steven soderbergh where he shoots
you know 15 to 20 pages a day one or two
takes i mean i was so excited because i
was
you know um previously aware of
of that process and i was so eager to do
it you know
flying by the seat of your pants
everybody that he hires comes to set
completely prepared
and you're not really given the chance
to second-guess yourself granted on the
project i worked with them on
this um project mosaic you know i think
that totality of the script
was something around the you know 500
pages or so that we shot within four
months
um you know the the different processes
i love i respect and admire them all
um and and you know i'm fortunate
to uh get to experience some i actually
watched you work on the set of tron
legacy
i was at the end of the line club and
got to see what that was like
i feel like the film has gained in
stature since it came out
you know when i talk to people about it
people genuinely like
a lot of people really respond to that
movie do you feel like
it's like do people still want to talk
about tron um what do you remember about
that shoot
and when you're talking about tricky
shoots as well
you know because a lot of the things
that we're doing creatively
aesthetically
technologically was was the first of its
kind and so you're the you're the
you know the first one exploring the
trial and error
of of what's going to work or not a lot
you know the suits for instance were
very challenging suits that
at the beginning because every light was
sort of hand
glued on inch by inch i mean it would
take us
two two and a half hours in the morning
just to put the suits on
and then the the the lack thereof being
able to bend
move this and that um um
you know the the the way you were
constricted within it
made it to be a very tricky process um
but you know i love it i i haven't seen
it
i'll definitely you know uh stop on it
when it's on once in a while and
and and um
[Music]
you know i have my um
my moments of uh the remembrance of past
times but um
the you know it was it was going to be
working with joe on it the studio was so
excited it was just
we knew we were doing something
revolutionary with it and so
you know i've been so proud of it so
honored to be a part of it and
you know working with my man jeff
bridges still dude and olivia
you know we we all became quite the
family on that one so
it was uh i have nothing but fond
memories
joe and i did a screening in imax laser
3d
i think like two years ago um and it
played like a rock concert
uh we had we played the volume super
high
and for like a hundred fans and we did
anyway the point is you were missed
but man it played huge we had such a
good time that night i will say one of
my
one of my uh fond memories of that shoot
was
i had this one of those prank pins one
of those gag pens that
that if you click the top of it because
you know the tip wasn't there
it'd electrocute you and i went around
to
first i started with daft punk when they
were on set and
asked them to sign my script and they
took a good zap and
you know i was raised the sort of merry
prankster and so
you know i continued to walk around the
rest of the day trying to
get as many casts and crew members as i
could with the old
electrocuting pen so that was one i
think it was you know maybe three
quarters way through the shooting
process and so
whatever you can do to sort of you know
reinvigorate those spirits and and sort
of
you know bring the energy and the morale
back up was i was all for it
uh i could talk to you about daft punk
for a long time but let's jump into why
i get to talk to you today
um a lot of people don't realize that
billie holiday
was a very early civil rights
like she was pushing civil rights well
before most people realize and
with their song strange fruit and you
think about musicians nowadays and
they're
scared to sometimes you know talk about
certain issues
but here she is in the late 30s uh
singing a song like that can you sort of
talk about the fact that
how early she was you know trying to
address civil rights
look there was a lot that i was unaware
of
um when i read the script um
you know it was an educational
experience
um the book chasing the scream johann
nari
that this was so softly based off of was
very in depth a lot of the material that
lee
sent me about my character in particular
harry anslinger
was completely unaware of um
her her experience and the heavy
opposition
malicious heavy opposition she faced
from the u.s government
forcing in strange fruit um
was was unbelievable um
you know for being an addict my
character's obsession with arresting her
for those two things was was just
um it was hard to to process and fathom
because i was such a fan
of billie holiday and have been i mean i
listened to it
to her religiously when i'm shooting on
the road you know
her cds and vinyls made up a lot of my
time of research for that film i was so
invested in
um i was so unaware of of
strange fruit being a civil rights
movement song
that the lyrics were about the act of
lynching um
anti-lynching um
[Music]
i was completely unaware and it just
made me realize that what i i was
embarking on with lee daniels on this
journey was going to be something so
powerful
you know what lee has gifted everybody
in in making this film
is what i realized was she was so
silenced
back then you know instead of being sent
to a hospital for being an
addict she was sent to prison to detox
when she got out her cabaret card was
taken from her so she couldn't even sing
in public
he put so many restrains on her that it
was almost
as if she would utter a breath
it was illegal and so the gift that lee
has has granted
this the new generations and generations
to come and the billie holiday legacy
is that that now she can once again have
a voice
and people will know the story because
it's so educational
i thought that andre did such a great
job
yeah and lee manages to craft these
performances
uh from his lead actors and his
supporting cast as well
that he just he always manages to craft
these great performances can you sort of
talk about collaborating with him and
maybe what you
you know how is he able to do this on
all of his movies
you know he sort of goes through and he
watches everything he
he hand picked everyone you know he sent
me
before the script was written he sent me
this big thick stack of material on
harry anslinger a year before
we started shooting maybe more and i was
very intrigued
um i'd never met with lee before we'd
known
um we'd had a a a lot of
friends in common evan ross being one of
them
terence howard and what have you and and
so i met with him on this material and
when i first saw a picture of anslinger
a younger version of him he kind of
looked like a al capone
and like an older version kind of looked
like a hitchcock i was
and i was curious i was like man you
want you want me
for this guy um you know as i was
almost a half between confused and
honored and i heard him out
and and send me more info in depth on
the true story and really wanted to get
down to the gist of of
you know sharing to the world billy's
real story and lady sings the blues that
diana ross had done harry anslinger was
still alive so they couldn't it was too
sensitive and subject for him to
to tackle you know this side of the
story this revelation
and so you know i was honored to
to play the part to be a piece of
one of lee's um you know wonderful
collaborative creatively artistic uh
puzzles that he
uh time and time again formulates i'm
not knowing i gotta go
uh really great to talk to you again i
wish you another guest
i'll see you on the next one man